a lawsuit against an Oregon fertility
clinic raises new concerns over how the
industry is regulated and overseen as we
first reported yesterday dr. Bryce
Cleary says his donated sperm was used
to conceive at least 17 children many of
them still living near him in an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning he tells Jamie yuccas that
thirty years ago he was told that would
not happen there's all kinds of things
that can go wrong with this for decades
when dr. Bryce Cleary thought of his
family he thought of his wife and four
children but he soon found out that he
had more children many more in fact when
the scope of this became so big it's
overwhelming 30 years ago
Cleary was a medical student at Oregon
Health and Science University he was
recruited by the school's fertility
clinic to donate sperm for infertile
couples and research programs Wednesday
he filed a lawsuit for more than five
million dollars against the University
in the suit Cleary says he was promised
that all fertilizations would be limited
to women not residing anywhere near the
state of Oregon and the Pacific
Northwest and no more than five children
would be born of a donor sperm I don't
know if it was written down I know it
was promised in 2018 Cleary registered
with ancestry.com he was shocked to
learn he had at least 17 offspring all
born in the Northwest including 25 year
old Alison Allie is it emotional it's
definitely emotional and it's definitely
shocking Allie has already met some of
her new siblings and as more and more
people get genetic testing she expects
to hear from others my kids could
potentially be friends with or later on
date cousins some siblings went to
schools the same schools at one point
could be churches basketball games pot
Luck's yeah you just don't know my
grandkids are gonna have to get DNA kits
before they seriously date that's a
problem sperm banking in America is big
business
Doug Fox is author of birth rights and
wrongs how medicine and technology
remaking reproduction and the law
there's no meaningful regulation on this
six billion dollar industry so burn
banks don't keep track of how many
people are created from any particular
donor it's hard to be all that surprised
when mishaps take place in a statement
Oh Hsu says it treats any allegation of
misconduct with the gravity it deserves
in light of our patient privacy
obligations and the confidentiality of
protected health information we cannot
comment on this case what is your goal
with filing the lawsuit my goal is to
get in to change there needs to be some
control to flood a zone with a bunch of
genetic material is completely
irresponsible for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Corvallis Oregon it's so
interesting to see the different
reactions for the children it means so
much to find out who the father father
is just so devastating yes he's upset
about that yeah maybe coming yeah all
right